Um, let's go next to our color from the eight
oh one area code.
Who's calling from eight Oh one today.
Okay.
Hi David.
This is John.
Hey John.
Salt Lake City.
What's going on?
And I had a question about the Democratic
primary.
Sure.
Um, yeah, I was curious, given that, uh, Harris
warn and Buddha, Jack Buddhists seem to be
vying for the same demographic or the same
voters.
Yep.
I'm wondering if in some sense there'll be
a ceiling for them and those voters, I see
them, maybe it's like middle class suburban
college educated.
Uh, and I think this ties in with an earlier
question you got from other, another color
y which I thought you think you were correct
on, but I think there might be something in
addition to what, what your response was.
In other words, a Biden and Sanders, even
though ideologically they're very different.
I think they both, uh, for different reasons
appeal to working class voters.
I don't know if that's the case for Harris
Warren or Buddha judge to the same extent.
Yeah, that's interesting.
So if I understand your question, is, will
Harris warn and Buddha judge by virtue of
sort of competing for a similar slice of the
electorate, will they hit a ceiling that will
preclude them from actually securing the nomination?
Exactly.
Is there a sort of zero sum game for those
three?
As long as they stay in, in the race and they
all stay
strong?
Well here's the thing,
PD for the same vote or
I don't know that that analysis apply.
I mean it's all zero sum in that there's some
number of votes that will be the total number
of ballots that will be cast in the Democratic
primary.
And it's in a sense it's all zero sum.
The question is I think whether there are
particular candidates that are going to cannibalize
votes from each other, from a certain electorate
in a way that we'll end up kind of having
a spoiler effect and letting someone like,
for example, Biden end up with the nomination.
I think the answer is no.
And here's why.
Before any votes are cast, we're going to
have a bunch more debates.
A whole bunch of people are going to drop
out there.
I can't imagine that when the first uh, caucus
starts in Iowa, you are going to have booted
Judge Harris, Warren, Biden, Sanders, and
d.
Did you mention one other?
Uh, I think those were the
good actually.
Okay, so you may, you actually may still have
all five of them, but here's the thing.
You know, the, the, I think that the polling,
even before any ballots are cast, is going
to consolidate around certain candidates in
Iowa.
You need 15% to get any delegates anyway.
So even if you have like a five way split,
not all five of them or are likely to end
up with delegates.
So I actually am not worried about this.
I think it's going to work itself out on its
own.
If the deep, my concern is the DNC shouldn't
put its finger on the scales, let's have debates.
Let's, let's figure it out.
Yeah, yeah, totally agree.
Totally agree.
Um, yeah, the only, I think what I was getting
at was that might be an advantage to per standards
because if Biden drops and it seems like there's
a good case to meet the need for that, that
uh, that Sanders will pick up working class
voters and not necessarily Harris Ward and
Buddha judge who would be buying for more
middle class, uh, educated voters.
Uh,
that's actually so interestingly about that.
When Biden had his initial decline from like
40 something percent in the polls to like
mid to hot, mid, mid thirties, Bernie was
getting about 80% of Biden's decline.
Meaning, like for every point, Biden was losing
Bernie seem to be getting at eight tenths
of a point and the other two tenths were going
to other people.
But in the last few weeks, Biden's declines
have been going more to Elizabeth Warren,
uh, to a certain degree, Pete Buddha judge,
and since the debates to Camila Harris.
So I think that generally speaking, you are
right that Bernie would be a big beneficiary
of Biden dropping, particularly because lots
of Biden voters say their second choice is
Bernie.
But I think that the last 10 days or so tell
us that other candidates may also gain from
Biden's losses.
We'll just have to wait and see.
Yeah.
Well, I really appreciate your spot.
Thank you.
Yep.
Thank you for the call.
Very, uh, very good to hear from you and I
hope to hear from you again.